To get started,
let's create a disc folder
that holds all generated files
separate form the source files.
This wasn't a problem with sass as we
generated the CSS into a separate high
level CSS folder.
But it would be with JavaScript
because we don't want our source and
distribution files to co-mingle.
The process is pretty simple.
We first copy our index.html
into the dist folder,
then generate our css into dist css, and
finally generate our combined
JavaScript file into dist JS.
Since we've already got our CSS set up,
let's change what's needed
in our styles task.
Here's our styles task
in the grunt file.
And we can see our destination is
set to just the CSS directory.
To make it show up under
this dist directory here,
we just changed
the destination to dist/css.
And, when we run gulp styles, we can see
that the files have been generated and
dropped in the correct folder.
Next, let's copy the index.html
in images to the dist folder.
We simply set up two new tasks and
call them something like copy-html and
copy-images.
In the copy-html task,
we grab the index.html file
with gulp.src and just pipe it to
the destination in the dist folder.
For the copy-images task, we do
the same thing, but instead of copying
a file or grabbing a locator to a file,
we're grabbing all the files
in a specific directory in piping
them to our new destination location.
You'll want to set up a new gulp.watch
next to the others that watches
the original index file.
You could do the same with the images,
but they don't change that often.
And don't forget to add the two
new tasks to the array that's
passed as part of the default task,
otherwise the files don't get copied
over the first time we run gulp.
Just a final fix before we can see our
page run again minus the Java Script
which will come in a bit.
You'll need to modify
the browserSync.init function call and
make it point to the dist directory,
now I've already done this for you.